The Joe Rogan experience.
The worst is if you try to valet a stick shift.
I tried,
I tried to give a valley my keys to my bronco and he didn't know what to do.
I go,
you don't know how to drive a stick shift.
He goes,
no.
I go,
what the fuck are you doing here man?
How can you have this job?
Yeah.
That should be a part of the resume.
I can't drive all cars.
It's crazy.
Yeah.
I don't think most people know how to,
you know they do what an under 30 can drive a stick?
I don't think so.
No,
it's going gone.
Yeah.
Porsche doesn't make them any more.
The only American muscle cars are one of the last holdouts like corvette and
Camaro.
I haven't driven a stick and a long time mustangs.
You know,
you want to try today.
Actually,
the last time I did,
I was in Costa Rica and I rented,
I rented a car and I'm like,
I just assume all cars now and when you rent them are automatics.
You know,
you get to know the country.
It's,
it's will it ever,
and so I'm pulling out of the a lot and it's like,
oh shit,
it's been a minute.
It's pretty embarrassing.
I got this.
Yeah.
When you're in Italy,
they all drive stick shifts.
Even like minivans.
Yeah.
It's weird.
Everything's a stick shift over there.
I'm not sure why.
I don't know.
What,
what's the advantages and disadvantages?
I mean,
what do you prefer?
Well,
if I was in where I was in Italy,
it was in Ravello,
which is a very small little roads.
It's very tiny and it's like crazy congestion because of tourism.
Yeah.
And uh,
the guy was always on the clutch back and forth,
back and forth.
I was like,
yeah,
this is,
you gotta be annoying as fuck.
You want an automatic and it,
it's like La,
right?
Like if you're in,
if you're commuting to la bumper to bumper every day,
you're going to want an automatic,
that's what happened.
Right?
I think you're right.
Yeah.
It's just more comfortable flipped,
flipped the car,
did the work.
But if you're on a mountain road,
like the angel's crest highway and you want to share,
there's something cool about being in command of the vehicle and you're telling
it when it's,
you know,
manly.
Yeah,
it is.
And if he got a dick in your hand and if it's a woman,
you got to go,
Ooh,
don't get too close to this one.
Yeah,
it's,
yes.
Driving's tick shifts like,
well,
she's a rebel.
She might be a problem.
Right?
She might be able to be great in bed though,
maybe.
Yeah.
For a little while.
And then didn't bigger house Adams.
She gets mad at you for email for 12 years ago.
I didn't even know you that.
What the fuck?
I can't go back and find this.
Where's that phone come from?
That's a flip phone once.
That's my Suki sidekick.
We were looking at that thing from ces at Jamie pulled up.
What does that goofy thing called?
These are good,
right?
I don't feel like I'm drinking a nonalcoholic beer.
Tastes like a regular beer.